skyscrapers are the symbol of wealth and
modernity
they dominate the skyline to the point
where they become intrinsic to a city's
image
investors politicians and the general
public seem to be loving them
and why wouldn't they skyscrapers are
big and shiny usually at least and a
true status symbol and i am here to ruin
the fun and tell you why skyscrapers are
actually pretty stupid and why we
shouldn't build them
my view is that in 99.9 of the cases you
don't even need to go above 10 floors
and so let's examine the main problems
with skyscrapers that prevent them from
being a good idea
problem number one is their
environmental impact because turns out a
big hunk of glass and metal is hard to
cool or heat
and to quote this guardian article about
it electricity use per square meter of
floor area was nearly two and a half
times greater in high rise of his
buildings 20 or more stories than in low
rises six stories or less
the gas used for heating was about 40
percent more for tall buildings and the
total carbon emission from these
buildings was twice as high
but hang on a second you might say it is
entirely possible to build
environmentally friendly skyscrapers
that aren't just a big mess of steel and
glass
to which i say sure but it still doesn't
solve the second problem
cost in general the taller you build the
more expensive it gets
and this is a problem because that means
affordable housing and affordable office
space are out the window
if big investors put up a bunch of money
to build a skyscraper
the first thing they will want is
returns and that usually doesn't mean
affordable one or two room apartments if
the spreadsheet says high-end luxury
condos equal most big number then that's
what's getting built
meaning that for skyscrapers to
meaningfully address the housing
shortage and not just become a rich
people tower the state would need to
step
in but the thing is if we really put up
an affordable residential skyscraper
with state support that still wouldn't
eliminate problem number three
alienation because turns out living on
the 50th floor makes it really difficult
to socialize with people
inside residential towers there is
rarely any meaningful social spaces
if you want any human contact you have
to go down to the park or something but
going down to the park from the 50th
floor is not the same as going down to
the park from the fifth floor
one takes five minutes and the other
takes 15. the lack of quick and easy
access to a social space promotes
alienation
people will just stay in their
apartments they will not get to know
each other here the best case scenario
is some people on the same floor kinda
knowing each other
whereas if you spread things out into a
nice low rise area with plenty of parks
and public spaces between the buildings
people will spend more time there and
socialize more because getting to those
places is no longer a hassle
problem number four is logistics if you
focus a lot of people in a small area
public infrastructure has to keep up
somehow aside from the need of gigantic
parking lots and high capacity public
transit
you also need to build out stuff like
daycare centers elementary schools high
schools
retail public communities and you also
need to scale this up for
tens of thousands of people and if you
have a bunch of office towers
you will end up with an area that is
extremely busy during work hours but
otherwise it's completely deserted
and so for me these are the four main
problems with skyscrapers
they are energy intensive unaffordable
they alienate you from other people
and they're quite a logistical headache
now in the beginning i've mentioned that
i don't think there's any need to build
anything taller than 10 stories
in 99.9 of cases and so let me show you
why
this is the burj khalifa it is 828
meters tall
and has 163 floors according to its fact
sheet
it has 172 000 square meters of
residential space
and 28 000 square meters of office space
so these numbers sound pretty impressive
right that's a lot of residential and
office space
and so i present to you this building
it's the so called falujas or village
house in budapest the biggest prefab
concrete residential block in hungary
from the 70s
the name village house comes from the
fact that this thing houses as many
people as an entire village
it has more than 3 000 inhabitants in
884 apartments
it's a 10 story building with a total
residential floor space of 43.5
000 square meters and so this right here
is the plot on which
the burj khalifa stands on it we could
easily fit five
entire village houses and if we turn
four of them into residential blocks and
one of them into an office
we get 174 000 square meters of
residential space
2 000 more and forty three point five
thousand square meters of office space
or fifteen point five thousand square
meters more
in other words five ten story talk comic
blocks was all it took to beat the
world's tallest skyscraper
and that should really tell us something
so to reiterate skyscrapers can only be
used for two things really
office space and residential space and
they're kind of bad at both of those
for residents skyscrapers are like any
other apartment building basically but
with the added disadvantages of living
very
high above the ground and the view might
be nice but trust me
it gets old really quickly and for
office workers
skyscrapers are well let's just say that
kovid 19 has shown us that we don't need
so much goddamn office space
because turns out most of us can work on
our computers just as easily from home
as we can in the office
and considering how most offices
nowadays are the open plan hellscapes
except for your bosses i think this is a
change for the better you know i really
do think that skyscrapers are just this
big dumb afterthought kind of solution
to the very real problem of lack of
housing stock and office space in major
urban settlements
but then why not start elsewhere why not
do intelligent complex urban planning
and eliminate instances of wasteful use
of public space
cars for example are a huge waste of
space they take up lots of space and
they spend
90 percent of their lifetime parked so
what if instead of building a skyscraper
we begin by reducing the number of cars
in the city and built some medium-sized
apartment blocks on the now vacant
gigantic parking lots
what if we reduced and regulated
short-term lease services like airbnb
because that alone can occupy a huge
part of the housing stock in any major
settlement
as you can see when it comes to handling
housing shortages and lack of space in
major cities
there's a myriad of other points where
we can start that are easier and more
effective oh and they also don't cost as
much as building a skyscraper
so this would be my case against them
i'm not completely opposed to the idea
though but i think they should be
considered only if we have exhausted all
the other previous available options
i think that would lead to much better
outcomes both for people and for cities
thank you for watching like and
subscribe if you haven't already and if
you want to show your appreciation for
my content then there is a patreon link
in the description
and i'll be seeing you next time